hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
God of War will go down as one of the
greatest games of 2018
the father-son journey of Kratos and
d'être us is only the beginning and
while we are waiting countless years for
a sequel to pop but I thought we should
take a look at the hidden messages
cultural references note to music and
film and a few secrets too inevitably
there will be a few narrative spoilers
along the way but if you're ready let's
go through 21 Easter eggs bound in God
of War Oh before we start I need to get
something out of my system boy boy boy
boy boy boy boy boy boy boy boy is it
boy okay no more references to how many
times Kratos says boy let's crack on the
game opens with Kratos cutting down
trees in a scene very similar to the
1980s movie commando Alice watts [ __ ]
does quite well with his puny axe and
sizeable tree carrying skills but of
course our Kratos does things a little
bit bigger and better there's a few more
similarities to commando as the story is
about a father and daughter who are
attempting to leave their past life
behind them but they find themselves
attacked at their wilderness home the
key difference is that Kratos undertray
us don't feed the deer they straight-up
murder that meal
good remember the God of War III demo
from back in 2016 about halfway through
the demo Kratos and the tray us walk
across this bridge only to be ambushed
by a troll in the final release of the
game this jump scare doesn't happen and
instead the dialog makes reference to
this change
oh I half expected to be a troll under
that bridge the troll fight is still
present in the game but it happens a
little bit later instead same outcome
though in both versions are IP random
trolls the God of War dev team openly
acknowledges Dark Souls as a source of
inspiration for their combat controls in
the game to honor Dark Souls a small
critter can be found early on in the
game which is bloody hard to kill this
crystallized little [ __ ] looks to be a
nod to the crystal lizards found in Dark
Souls and guess what they were
notoriously annoying to find and
bludgeon to God of War brought in
another actor to play Kratos this time
around this is because the mocap needed
to create the game required someone with
similar physical attributes to Kratos up
steps Chris judge a hulking
six-foot-three actor with dulcet tones
perfect for the aging Kratos or award
you judge is best known for playing
Teal'c in the sci-fi series Stargate
sg-1 that characters trademark
catchphrase was indeed indeed and lo and
behold it makes a brief comeback in god
of what indeed during a key battle with
Grendel of the ashes Atreus and Kratos
come out victorious leading to this
throwaway life
this is actually a nod to the first
Avengers movie back in 2012 the see when
Loki meets The Hulk face to face midway
through the game now so spoilers are
plentiful Kratos and at Reyes eventually
reach this puzzle in which they have to
name the seasons of the year and this
interaction takes place why start with
winter I know that one liked music I got
it the song the head is about to start
singing looks to be an old Carole King
song called you've got a friend and the
iconic line winter spring summer or fall
oh you've got to do is car oh no oh God
my own mother sang this to me as a child
so I can see why the creators would
include this in the game lovely touch
although God of War may be a reboot of
sorts the story does follow on from the
original games back on the ps2 and ps3
the game makes repeated references to
the previous saga such as Kratos has a
huge hulking scar through his torso from
the moment he looked to have killed
himself at the end of God of War 3
there's loads more the returning blades
of chaos the cameo from Athena and even
their father Zeus makes an appearance in
Hell to compound the influence of Zeus
Kratos even quotes his pop up when it's
time to kill the stranger the cycle ends
here
over limbus the cycle ends here
[Music]
why do you walked away the cycle ends
here must be better than this
the cycle ends here other references are
a little more subtle such as the VARs of
ACE VARs face de vars isn't it anyway
crackin such as the VARs with great
hosts image upon it and the color scheme
of black and red those who played God of
War 3 will be able to identify this as
the fear skin when wearing this in that
game it increased the enemy attacks by
400% has anyone found that skin or
costume in the new God of War I want it
so bad good another subtle nod to God of
War 2 and the sisters of fate our
reference to with this interaction
between the other hand what does it say
knowing here
the fates fit no good comes from them
but without a doubt the greatest
reference back to the original god of
war trilogy comes in the shape of the
treasure map for the boat captains key
back in God of War on the ps2 the first
task kratos undertakes is to defeat a
Hydra which he does by impaling it
through the ships sail he then goes into
the Hydra to save the boat's captain or
does he seek yourself
thank you thank the gods you came back
for me
I didn't come back later on in the game
Kratos meets the boat's captain once
again let go fool
you won't drag me down to that curse
said River there is a test left for me a
boss pleaded you again
go
[Applause]
after being dropped to his certain death
the boat captain reappears in God of War
two
during kratos his fight with the
barbarian king ulrich summons the dead
to fight alongside him and one of those
countless enemies happens to be the boat
captain who reacts like this no he'll
run around the battlefield and poses
zero threat to kratos so take him out as
you see fit his reference in God of War
Suri is much more subtle and comes in
the form of a note in Hell which reads
he could have saved me he had my life in
his hands and still he let go I may have
been a mere boat captain but he treated
me as if I was nothing he is to blame
for my torment here I hope he suffers in
Hades as I have damned the Ghost of
Sparta back in the new god of war now
and the boat captains key treasure has
more to add to this subplot reading with
the boat's captain in the belly of the
Hydra the key was mine I traveled to a
new land but my ship wrecked and sunk so
the story of that key and the boat
captain is not yet over expect to pick
this one up when God of War two rolls
out in God of War the sons of Thoth
Modi'in Magni may sound a little
familiar under the all-father demands it
they are voiced by vo heavyweights nolan
north and Troy Baker who superbly played
another set of famous brothers in
another PlayStation exclusive uncharted
both have also appeared in the Last of
Us which was a huge inspiration to the
God of War developers next we have
another easter egg referencing the
Marvel Universe again this time it's
Avengers infinity war and Thanos sees
favorite garment the Infinity Gauntlet
this is part of a side quest the mission
family business ends on a boat but just
before you can leave the area Kratos is
attacked by this jet broke loose off
dispatching him drops the shattered
gauntlet of Ages when equipped the
animation resembles the Infinity
Gauntlet and can be upgraded to achieve
extra damage and other perks the rune
slots can be upgraded and around the
world it's possible to find all six
Infinity stones from the Marvel Universe
but they've been adapted for copyright
reasons but keep in mind you'll only
require three to fully utilize the
Infinity Gauntlet oh you'll also need
dragon tears - so this quest will take
you a long time if you were lucky enough
to pick up one of the special editions
of God of War you'll get this cloth map
to savor while this bad boy holds a
secret a group of super fans translated
the ancient texts and somehow figured
out what to do to unlock the secret item
in short Kratos must stand a top of the
muscle hind tower on the centre circle
once in position face the temple then
turn left to the fire back to centre
right left center down to the floor
right left center once more if all is
right a gong will acknowledge your axe
now step forward and receive your reward
by the way if it doesn't work leave the
area by the door behind and return again
the legendary axe pommel is pretty
useful too I'm going to throw this one
in quite quickly here have you noticed
the resemblance the statues around the
world have with the Lord of the Rings
The Watchmen in particular look straight
out of Gondor and there's even a mission
where at Reyes picks up the ring which
starts to speak to him and may be
cooking at straws here and on second
thoughts it's probably more likely the
Lord of the Rings films borrowed from
Norse mythology rather than the other
way round but I'm not sure what do you
think - end let's look at the brilliant
of foreshadowing in God of War that's
where you hint at something early on
which then comes to fruition later in
the game or story if you've got to this
point in the video I'm sure you've
finished the game but if you haven't
quick run while you can join the
conversation in which Kratos tells his
son he's a god at Reyes asks
turn into an animal
and you turn into an animal
no no I do not think so does that have
finished the game know that Atreus is
actually the god Loki and that question
references Norse myth which tells us
Loki can indeed shape-shift he said to
become a fish a horse and even a fly he
can also turn into human-like beings too
he's also said to be the father of
yeoman Gander so expect a little time
travel in future games the foreshadowing
even happens in the opening fight with
the stranger during the battle Kratos
drops a boulder on Balder as a joke
there is no joke intended but there's
actually a stone carving or painting on
the rock which gives away the plot of
the game the full carving is revealed in
the last moment of the story but the
eagle-eyed of you saw it in the first 30
minutes so with that knowledge of
foreshadowing it's possible to break
down so many more elements within the
game I counted around 20 possible hints
to future content and sequels but the
one which stood out the most occurs when
Dad and boy reach Odin's abode and
discover the symbols of war from around
the world we already know about the
Omega sign which we've taken to signify
the God of War in Greek mythology but
there are three other locations Kratos
could be heading to after this trilogy
in the top-left corner is the Eye of
Horus from Egyptian origins there's also
a swirling pattern in the bottom left
and right corners which are used in both
Japanese symbolism and Celtic following
pagans which represent their three
goddesses and three worlds controlled by
the Sun the Japanese version uses black
and white to signify good and evil light
and dark I don't know about you but
futile Japan would be an awesome place
to visit as the Ghost of Sparta in fact
where would you like Kratos to go next
what about Egypt's and that could be
really cool after seeing what Assassin's
Creed have done there I would love to
see the God of War record those babies
and finally the secret ending that so
many people have missed which sets up
the main antagonist for God of War 2
after completing the main campaign take
yourself and your boy for some rest and
relaxation back at your home then sit
back and enjoy this
[Music]
four versus Kratos
I cannot wait for that one
so there we have it 21 Easter eggs
references and occasional secrets to I
do hope you've enjoyed this Whistlestop
tour of god of war and if you haven't
played it yet i implore you to do so
it's a real masterpiece I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade and if you've made
it to the end do me a favor write in the
comments captain buttmunch I will reply
to you you have my word thanks for
sticking around I really do appreciate
it I will see you next time
[Music]